good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please
allow me to welcome you to this edition
of our 20 20 21
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and by a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it's my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker
dr robert williams who is the u
university of tennessee oak ridge
national laboratory governor's chair in
computational genomics
again from the university of tennessee
he completed his bachelor's degree in
psychobiology from the university of
california santa cruz in 1975
and earned his phd in physiology from
the university of california davis
in 1983. from 1983 to 1985 he was a
postdoctoral fellow
at yale university school of medicine in
the section of neuroanatomy where he was
supervised
by the famous and noteworthy pasco
rakish
his professional experience involves a
number of different positions
um mainly at the university of tennessee
over the almost the last 25 to 30 years
he's also held positions at the
university of california davis
at yale university and
has had many organizational and societal
leadership roles amongst his many
activities and many pursuits professor
williams has an intense interest in
systems genetics complex
complex trait analysis and functional
genomics
as well as the control of gene
expression the genetics of cns disease
and addiction
the role of the environment in disease
modeling of neurological syndromes
visual system architecture function and
development
he's also been very concerned with
advanced methods in collaborative
research and data sharing
over the last several years he has led
the
informatics center for mouse
neurogenetics at the university of
tennessee
and this effort hosts the mouse brain
laboratory and
expanding collection of high-resolution
histological images atlases and
databases on brain structure
in more than 120 different lines of
experimental mice
working in his laboratory includes
several useful
or sorry work in his laboratory include
several useful genetic
and gene mapping databases um i and as
we were talking before
we began today he reminded me that the
gene network dot org
database has been in constant operation
since 1995.
he's been a key participant in a number
of several large nih-funded programs
including the nih human brain project
and more recently the nih brain
initiative he has won
numerous awards including the lauren d
carlson award prize in physiology
the fellow award for the winter
conference in brain research
as well as many others his lecture today
is entitled data structure disease risk
gxc
and causal modeling and as always if you
are
watching this video via youtube we
welcome you
and also our specially selected 2020
2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr williams via the chat feature
in your zoom session i'll synthesize
these questions and i will ask them on
your behalf
in the last 10 minutes or so of dr
williams lecture
and with that welcome rob we really
appreciate your lecture
and look forward to hearing from you
delighted to be here jack
thank you very much for the invitation
and for that uh
very very kind introduction um
this will be i've been accused of giving
lectures a little bit
like toad's wild ride at disneyland and
so
strap strap in well i'll try to get
through
quite a bit but leave enough time for
you to ask questions and for me to
attempt
to answer your questions the premise is
right up here
and i think jack already highlighted
some of these ideas
virtually all of the diseases we care
about
the ones that are pervasive that are
age-related
are a mix of genetic factors and
variants
and lots of lots of environmental
factors
and of course the non-linear interaction
between those two
extremely tough problem to solve
particularly when you're dealing with
human genomes where
each one of us unless we're fortunate
enough to have an identical twin
is an n of one genome uh so
the the kind of challenge
uh slash hubris of accurate medicine
or precision health care
it it's really going to be difficult
frankly because
with an n of one it's difficult to
establish models it's difficult to know
what's good for you in specific it may
not be
daunting to figure out what's good in
general for a population
but figuring out what it what it would
be truly
individualized healthcare that is going
to be
very difficult so the tasks that i've
set myself over the last 20 years
even before we you know had this phrase
precision healthcare
is how to build up systems data systems
that will allow us to
approach the problems and so the first
top part of my talk i'm really going to
be talking about data types in a way
that i think is a bit unusual
um and i'll explain that but the
bottom line is we need new types of data
uh steven friend used to call this or
maybe still does call this coherent
data what is coherent data and i'm going
to re-badge that
as multiplicative uh data types
and i'll show you how we're able to
generate multiplicative data types
and the important thing about having
multiplicative data types
is that the lifespan of the data
is exceedingly long the quality of the
data
oddly enough actually improves with age
and so you can be sure that if you make
generate the right kind of data using
the right data generation
process your data will outlive you
and presumably become more and more
valuable as the context
in which that data lives those data live
become
um richer essentially
i'm going to focus mainly on
neurogenetics because that is my my area
of strength
but a little bit on aging which is why
this grim reaper cartoon
is also relevant so
let's go to
so the first question a lot of you are
are formal data scientists and i'm going
to introduce what i think is a new term
smart data well maybe it's not so so so
new
there's the the classic fred brooks
quote in the upper right
write stupid code that uses smart
objects
smart data and then the rule at the
bottom rule 5
of rob pike data dominates if you've
chosen the right data structure and
organize things well the algorithm
will almost always be self-evident data
structures not algorithms are central to
programming
i think that's an arguable statement
especially in this ai
driven world now but it it
reveals something that's very important
there's a lot of data generation
a lot of consideration about curation
cleanup wrangling of data
but less so about the nature
the fundamental nature of data
so what do i mean by smart data and you
know i could read through this but
do we need good metadata data without
great metadata is really not data at all
of course the data has to be qc'd for
outliers has to be transformed just to
be
wrangled it has to be stabilized and put
into
a data structure preferably one that's
free in open source software so that you
can get at it
unless there are confidentiality issues
hipaa issues
so we want our data to be fair
but i would argue that fair isn't nearly
enough and
fair data while it may not evaporate
it is really generally
only additively useful and i've shown
the ice cube metaphor there in the
in the middle left of the slide most
data sets we generate
alas particularly those that are
generated by nih
ro1s are
are vulnerable to evaporation and there
have been a several challenges
both for data and for code can you go
back 10 years
in your lab in your research career and
fish out your 10 year old data
and rerun the same algorithm you ran 10
years ago
that is an extremely challenging task
and we tried it here
um about three months ago just to see
how far we could get
we did get 10 years back one of one of
us one of my colleagues got 20 years
back
but it's it's tough so most data
exists for the purpose of writing your
cool paper
after your cool paper has been written
most of your data
is now essentially orphaned
and if it lives on past five or ten
years
then you're doing something right but
it's still
additive data in other words your data
might add to the corpus
of data but it's not multiplicative so
i'm going to explain what i mean by
multiplicative data pretty soon
just some examples of what i regard as
multiplicative data
multiplicative data is data where if you
add one vector
of data or one matrix of data it
integrates with many other vectors and
matrix or tensors of data
and now instead of just adding one
correlation or
one edge to a network you're adding
one times whatever is already in that
system
so in my case for gene network for the
bxd
family we have billions of millions of
phenotypes sorry
and for every additional vector we now
have millions
of correlations that we that are
actually not just
correlations or in a causal network as i
will explain
but framingham heart study is a good
example of multiplicative data
the genome genotype to tissue expression
database
protein database allen brain atlas and
gene network these are
a few they're actually quite a few of
these of course
they tend not to be r01 work though they
tend to be
large program projects that have been
shepherded quite carefully by
nih staff including people like phil
bourne
and and jack
even if the data are multiplicative very
few of these data sets
come with integrated code and services
that can be used long term
so geo is a good example of the gene
expression omnibus
of a massive data but there's not much
you can do with it if you're a mere
mortal if you happen to be a really good
data wrangler then you can do something
with it
but but it's a major effort because geo
actually doesn't provide
sophisticated analysis services and then
here's the final challenge what really
makes data smart
is if the data gets better with age and
i i can't you know it's
so few day to get better with age it's
ridiculous but data should
in principle get better with age so
um so what does smart multiplicative
data look like
so i'm going to give you a real world
example of this but the
the short version is i'm interested in
brain weight you know in the next slide
i'll show you
you know what what's the motivating
question for me but
i'm particularly interested in brain
architecture and its variability
um mouse brains weigh for different
strains weigh anywhere from about 380 to
520 milligrams so half a gram
roughly but there's a wide range so you
can see there one of the strains of mice
the one that's sort of a beige brown
color
has a brain that's 402 milligrams on
average
and the other uh strain of mouse black
six has a brain that's about
471 milligrams on average
and the error terms are very small in
this case because we've
studied literally hundreds of these
animals under all different kinds of
conditions
and by the way to to finesse any
question
there is zero sex difference in brain
weight in uh
mice and i've looked at several hundred
strains so uh brain weight differences
despite the smaller body weight of
females
it just doesn't happen in mouse
so if i generate a vector of data in
this case we have data for about
95 different strains of mice
what can i do with that data so that's a
vector of numbers 95 deep
and now i can compute correlations of
that vector
with anything else i happen to have
measured in the same
family of mice and we happen to have
measured
millions of traits in the same family of
mice and you can see in the lower right
a correlation matrix of behavioral
traits expression traits
with brainwave traits so in that sense
the if i add one vector i
add millions of correlations and as i
show you that
is not merely correlation
and if you wanted to get to the this
particular data set that i'm showing you
right there
there's the web url any of you can click
on that
web url or type it in god forbid
and it'll take you to essentially this
histogram and you can play with it
and you can calculate the correlations
so that's what i mean
by multiple multiplicative data
for the bxd family these are jack
mentioned that i
i have an interest in gene expression
both protein expression in brain for
which we have
precious little data for any species
and gene expression where the platform
has enabled us to get generate a lot of
data
over the last 20 years but here's these
are
massive expression data sets for
hippocampus
from these same animals for which we
have brain weight
so we have hippocampal precursor cell
expression data
we have exxon array data we have
proteomics data
and i'll give you a live tour of some of
that at some point
so why i needed uh smart data
uh so when i started so i as jack
mentioned i was a postdoc with
pashkurakish and developed some methods
for counting cells
in poshko's highly highly diverse
collection of mouse brains some were
processed in paraffin some in soloidan
some frozen sections
they were a histological mess of
confounds
and i developed a method that now most
of you probably know is a dissector
method
we called it three three-dimensional
counting
which allowed us to get accurate
stereological uh data out of this
hodgepodge
of um and the reason i was interested in
this because i really wanted to know
how how are how are neurons in
particular but glial cells also and even
endothelial cells
how are the numbers of those cells
deployed
across different cns systems to generate
function and behavior
it's a question you might be
able to answer for one structure in five
or ten years
but if you're interested in answering
that question across the whole central
nervous system
even of a small brain species like a
mouse you're looking at hundreds if not
thousands of discrete cell populations
as we now know
and the stereology simply didn't scale
so it was a question that couldn't be
answered in a stupid
one at a time non-scalable method
so my my progression um
sort of following the technology so
excel was introduced in 1987
and of course i leapt on it because it
was a huge boon
from doing things in a lab notebook god
forbid so at least it was one step up
from a
hard copy lab notebook it's still
unfortunately
maybe fortunately the lingua franca uh
lowest common denominator
of data sharing uh with all of its warts
and ugliness and stupidity
but it has worked to a great extent
and unfortunately i still use it i can't
i can't get away from it um the second
step is to move obviously to relational
databases
uh the simple guys the the microsoft
accesses and filemakers
then to the the my sequel maria
db postgres going to
open source uh relational databases is a
big leap for most
ro1 funded labs it's actually a huge
leap because you need
a lot of expertise and it's not
expertise you hire for a couple of
months
you when you move into this domain
you are hiring somebody for the rest of
your career unless you are that person
so we've had one or two dbas working on
the systems i'll tell you since about
1990
myself initially when i had some
level of technical competence but now
real pros
and then if you want to do what i wanted
to do which was live analysis
of all of the data that i would gather
over my career
you you can't say okay i'm going to do
it in r
script and hope to come back to that r
script in 10 years the r script is going
to be too slow
it's going to be clunky the whole you
know somebody's going to say no don't
don't use r use rust because it's way
cool and it's got better garbage
collection
or no garbage collection or use whatever
d
so it's it's a constantly moving uh
battle so
we we opted for web service
um you know i think it was a fortuitous
decision we didn't know where the web
was going to go in 1995 but
uh gene network started as something
called the portable dictionary of the
mouse genome um and it's
still still going strong
okay uh so those were kind of my
my steps forward um oh
and i think i've uh yeah so
three key resources to approach this
question so how are neurons generated
how do they survive how are they
maintained
uh throughout lifespan what are the
genetic factors
and environmental factors that do that
so on the right of this slide you see
your
typical motherhood and apple pie
data science slide going all the tiers
of analysis from dna variants at the
bottom
snips indels bear and uh you know cnbs
at the top environment disease factors
so sort of progressing up the tiers
if you ask 90 of biologists
what those little brown and orange
arrows represent
they will have no idea they will say oh
it's some kind of magic integration
arrow and they say well how do you
actually
integrate across all these levels i said
well
i don't know but you just get a mess of
data for
your mouse say c57 black 6 or dba
and now you're going to be able to
integrate that data if you're lucky
and that's essentially the approach that
the allen brain atlas did
where they spent close to 300 million
dollars
studying c57 black six male
gene expression at 56
days of age that's an n of one study
that cost about a third of a billion
dollars
i want you guys to think about that
because um
i've been arguing with them for a long
time they did a wonderful thing for the
allen brain atlas so it's a it is a good
expenditure of money
but it's not a great expenditure of
money why is it not
great because it's an n of one
experiment that somebody just blew 300
million dollars on
fortunately it wasn't nih it was paul
allen
but they could have done so much more if
they had incorporated genetic diversity
and so kind of in a parallel
uh skunk works project that's what i've
been doing i'm trying to essentially do
allen brain atlas times about 10
000 using now state-of-the-art methods
and that's what i call systems genetics
so instead of an n of one
i'm going to look at my knockout or my
knock-in we're going to use
integrative genetically aware in other
words variational wear not gene aware
but variation aware
approaches that allow us to compute
models
roc curves and
get to true prediction and in order to
do that we need
a genetics reference family a stable
immortal family of experimental
subjects i call them genome types
they're not genotypes but it's a whole
genome
type that we can use forever and ever
all men as
walt disney would say throughout the
known universe
and these mice are a stable resource
they've been cryopreserved
your grandchildren will be able to come
back to them in 100 years
rederive essentially the same mouse that
you studied
we've generated 150 of these over the
last
30 40 years they've been very well
sequenced in all of the data
is almost all of the data is in gene
network and so the idea is to get
high sample size to go to gene locus to
gene variant to mechanisms and to
treatment options
and to answer the question i ask
initially what are these arrows
represent
initially they represent correlations
but they represent correlations in a
causal
modeling environment which we get
courtesy of the central dogma
which is to say that gna dna variants
cause phenotype variants not the other
way around so we have the causal
polarity that we need
so this is the result of the second and
third decades of work
in gene network i'm going to just take
you through
a little bit of this this is the example
i already used once the brain weight
in males and females the 94
different different strains males and
females averaged and i said there's no
difference between the sexes so in this
case we don't even
have to fit that as a cofactor although
we could
um and anybody who wants to explore
these data either as a data scientist
interested
in some fancy new algorithm
this is the most coherent phenome data
bar none for any collection of organisms
at this point there's nothing that
approaches it in terms of replication
in terms of depth uh etc
and i will try to prove that i'm i'm
bragging obviously but let me i will try
to prove that
and i just want to point out that all of
this smart data and all these
correlations
the family has been fully sequenced
fully genotyped
it's like a linkage study it's like
tracking down the gene variant that
caused huntington
in the venezuelan population back in the
in the 80s and 90s so we can map
the causes of variation to the genome
that sometimes goes by
the name of a linkage analysis or
association analysis
these are very unfortunate terms because
this is not
mere linkage it's not mere association
it's a causal assertion
it's a causal model so in this plot that
you're looking at here that's called the
manhattan plot
on the y-axis you have the minus log p
of the association so uh you know
a value of six is pretty pretty good
that's point zero
zero zero zero zero one is a likelihood
of uh of a false discovery there at a
conventional
uh criterion on the x-axis
are all of the chromosomes of a mouse
except chromosome y in the mitochondrial
genome
and you can see we have two spots one on
chromosome five
and one on chromosome 12 that have lod
scores above about 3.8
and those are considered genome-wide
significant so there's a
false discovery rate of about oh
one in call it one in a thousand
or better for that locus on chromosome
five in other words
we know that there is a cause causal
locus on chromosome 5 that modulates
brain weight
with that that caveat that the p value
is good
but obviously it's not perfect um so
this is a causal model
and all of this work actually we started
in as part of the human brain project
that jack mentioned
so that is how we can add causality to
any correlation
in gene network and
we have a a software stack the entire
stack is on
github it's all open source you could
just do a complete fork and have a copy
at uva
and i'll tell you i would be totally
delighted if you did that
because we need more smart analysts
and coders we can't do this ourselves
so coming back to that original question
what genes control variation or what
gene variants control
variation in brain structure
here's here's our first conclusion from
a nature communications paper in 2012
on the lower right you can see us
literally
hand dissecting chunks of the brain
hippocampus striatum olfactory bulb
cerebellum all of those just were hand
dissected
quite tedious but quite high throughput
and from that those data those became
vectors of data so there was a vector of
data for
how much is the olfactory weight weigh
how much is a cerebellum way how much
what is the volume of the cortex or the
striatum of the basal lateral amygdala
or the lateral geniculate nucleus and
what you see around that sagittal
section
are so-called qtl maps of the type i
just showed you in this slide
but now with continuous functions rather
than points for each snip
so these are just the continuous version
so this is cortex
hippocampus whole brain which i just
showed you in the previous slide
body weight as a cofactor cerebellum
algae and striatum bla
and olfactory bowl these data were
published eight years ago
they are now much better than they used
to be because our genotypes for all
these animals
are much much improved and we've
sequenced all of these strains
using linked read technology so the old
data
got better with age and i could you know
if if this were
a jupiter lab notebook i could give you
this paper and say push this button
update it to the latest and greatest
version of these data
and you could then tweak the model you
could say oh i don't like the way he
modeled x
y uh we have to have sex as a co-factor
or do the interaction term
and all that would be possible if this
data were embedded in the right web
resource
it turns out it more or less is
so today so this is where where jack and
i were having fun before the
the before we got started here
so it still doesn't scale cutting up
brains
literally with a with a scalpel is not
the smartest way to do this the smartest
way to do this
is with magnetic resonance imaging but
magnetic resonance imaging has not been
high throughput
at the resolution required for the work
that i'm interested in doing
but fortunately as part of the human
brain project and the
and the burn network after that i struck
up a
a really great collaboration with
g allen johnson and duke the director of
the center for in-vivo microscopy there
who
is a physicist and mri guru who has been
lucky for me adopted by the neuroscience
community
and so he he is now this is a paper that
just came out a few
about a month ago each one of these
images that you're seeing here this is a
horizontal section through the mouse
brain
in skull so the skull has been stripped
but this is
in situ so to speak olfactory bulb at
the top
cerebellum at the bottom this is this
this is an
overlay of four brains from a black six
male c
57 black six the mother of our bxd
family
this is uh same thing for for four
females and i just want you to look at
the male female difference
again the registration of these sprains
within an isogenic strain are just
phenomenal
and they're subtle quantitative
differences that won't leap
out at you except over here where we
don't have a corpus callosum
in the btbr strain you can see the
connection across the midline is missing
but what's amazing to me is the
similarity between male and female
within strain
even to little dorky things having to do
with the shape of the olfactory bulbs
um it's it's it's just it's just
striking how tight the genetic control
is
and how little uh little there is in the
way of sex difference
in this particular case obviously for
those of you who are sex difference
aficionados
i don't understand it humans are
obsessed by sex and i'm just trying to
wrap my head around that and i still
i still really can't um but
you can i you know there are going to be
some sex
differences down here in the pre-optic
area but
um really the amazing thing is how
similar
male and female mouse brains are and
i think the same at a at a
appropriate generalization is also true
of humans
the within the between strain difference
the genetic variation however
is very sizable um
so that's the the um the mri
and the the connectomes which you see
there so we're actually
following the diffusion metrics of water
protons to see which way the tracks run
but we can now combine this with light
sheet
uh just some more uh just another one
but here's
uh we can combine it with um
with functional mri so this is
a black six male uh mice over here and
the
and the d2 the two parents just looking
at
resting state fmi from marcelo fibo's
group
at the the gainesville magnetic
residence national center
and catherine kozrowski at jackson
laboratory
so they've been doing mri of
not only the parents but they have been
bold enough to do start doing the the
resting state connectome
uh the fmri connectome for the for the
bxd
uh progeny children and so there's
amazing stuff
that can be done and i uh just this
morning whoops coined this
ridiculous word polyphenol so
a phenome should in principle be
everything but i just want to emphasize
that this is really
everything everything including the
environmental perturbations
uh the genetic perturbations so we can
do mri we can do light sheet we can do
proteomics of brain or any other
chunk we can do developmental studies
epigenomics behavioral studies obviously
and you end up with something like this
a polytope or a matrix or a tensor
showing everything related to everything
else so in this case it's just a
looking at the variability of brain
regions such as cortex
with other regions so you can see that
the neocortex
doesn't really care much about the
hindbrain but it does care
quite a bit about the striatum which
makes a good
good deal of sense and call it cares
about so you can look at these
correlation structures
again in a genetic context so imagine
the third
dimension of this being the mapping data
for every one of those
those cells in that matrix
um and i think i wanted to show you okay
so
this is a slide i wanted to show you now
adding so we take the brain
in situ and we do the mri at about
45 micron resolution then
the brain is removed from the skull
it of course gets distorted when we do
that we ding the cortex and we you know
an olfactory bulb or parafocus falls
off whatever it then goes to boston in
life
canvas uh one of carl dieserall's
ace postdoc chung set up a company
called life
canvas technology to basically spread
the word
and spread the practice of shield and
clarity so
the these whole brains are then
clarified and you can then
antibody you can you know use as many as
three four channels
to studies any cells you want so in this
case
it's tyrosinase i'm sorry tyrosine
hydroxylase
in dopaminergic neurons in the ventral
midbrain and then just a stain for
gfp um you can see the resolution is
is in two orders of magnitude better
uh on a linear scale than what we
achieve with the mri
so now you get the cytology but you've
got it in beautifully segmented regions
of interest
from the mri which is unrivaled in terms
of
distortion free analysis and i just want
to
escape here for a second and show you
what some of these brains look like
so
[Music]
this is an egfp a brain
that was imaged by mri then sent to
boston
for imaging and you can count every cell
here
that's expressing the enhanced green
fluorescent protein
that's the trigeminal motor nucleus you
see over there
you can see the spinach corticospinal
tracts
looping down you can see the projections
from the subiculum
looping forward and every cell
is countable here and so you're doing
whole brain
potentially a whole brain stereology now
this is a pretty picture
pretty movie um i'll tell you it's very
much state of the art to convert
something like that to numbers
um and that's where we're going now with
a lot of help from a lot of
a lot of folks let's see i want to get
back here
to
[Music]
hang on a second while i clutz around
okay so that just if you want to go to
life canvas tech
um that that's their hero screen though
the one i just showed you they have
several hero screens
but that's the first one um
so i've i'm up i'm at 11
37 now um so kind of a new topic here
and this has to do with
why animal models are coming in with a
tremendous
for tremendous amount of intellectual
flack
so you may not know it but nimh
essentially won't
fund certain types of animal model work
because
the the current director of nih happens
to think that
mice don't mouse data doesn't translate
well
and i hate to say it but he's absolutely
correct
but he's absolutely correct for the
wrong reasons and that's because
he and other leaders at nih have allowed
a sociology of n equals 1
to proliferate for the last 30 years
so in the interest of standardization
we've been left with
one mouse so
i would say that 90 95
of all studies you read that use a mouse
model
use one genome of mouse it's either c57
black 6j
or c57 black 6nj or it's about cj
or it's fvb or it's btbr if you're
interested in autism
this is completely ridiculous
because it's an n of one study i don't
care if you studied
50 knockouts 50 heterozygous in 50 wild
types
it is an n of one genome that you're
studying and you may
consider the results to be necessary and
sufficient
you may get your high profile paper in
neuron or cell
or science but it is still an end of one
study
and as a matter of fact it's less than
an n of one study
because every mouse that is studied is
essentially a single genome it's not
even
got the decency to have two genomes
within its single body it's
a fully inbred strain of mouth so it's
really an n of 0.5
in the same way that finally after about
40 years nih decided to mandate that we
shall study males and females
they're still letting us slide by
studying one
genome type of mouse it's inexcusable
and it's doubly inexcusable because it
accounts
almost perfectly for the failure of
transportability
of data from mouse to human and
translations
to fail because we don't even have
robust results for our mouse
results you get in c 57 black six do not
translate to bound cj they do not
translate to dba 2j
they certainly don't translate to rat
why should they
it's like saying that this in this
figure from all of us
that the old white guy in this figure
he's going to represent all of us so
forget about all that genetic diversity
that all of us put in their figure there
no we're only going to study uh 70
kilogram white guys
that's what biomedical research did for
about 50 years as everybody painfully
knows
finally we've gotten beyond that we've
gotten beyond that for
human clinical research but not
for the billions of dollars we spend
every year on mouse and rat research
so you can you can kind of get a feel
for the aggravation
that i have i just i just um
i'm horrified by this and i'm i'm glad
to at least have a bully
pulpit here for for you know a few
minutes to point out
this inexcusable stupidity of of what
we're doing
so we cannot generalize so and
all that genetic variation has to go
into our models
so how do we add variation to improve
the transport and translation
to humans well my simple step has been
take two inbred strains at least
mix them up and now you've got a family
a mixed up family
and here's the simple pedigree you know
this goes back to
genetics not even 101 genetics one basic
basically mendel uh could have
understood this
we've got two inbred strains black 6 and
dba2j
we make the f1 inner cross which is
shown there f1
then we make an f2 intercross meiotic
randomization
exactly what mendel did in 1864.
and the only trick is that we now once
we get our f2
progeny we put them in a cage and
inbreed them for 20 generations and we
end up with another
inbred strain actually we've got 152 of
these inbred strains
that we've made and it costs about 25 to
30 000
to make each one of these strains and so
i'm thankful for funders
for letting me go off on this deep deep
dive into making resources
um and i mentioned all of them have been
sequenced so that's what it looks like
and you can see we have this meiotic
randomization
this is what fisher did starting in the
20s so the randomization here comes from
meiosis which is more or less
random it's very close to being a
randomizing process that
allows us to extract causality so what
about these bxds
they're obviously adorable
each strain here is immortal so that's
why i said you can come back to these
strains in 100 years they're all
cryopreserved
yes mutations will happen but you can
roll it back
in time by getting your preserved stock
each strain comes in a male female
version so this is incredibly powerful
in terms of looking at sex differences
if you do a paired t-test with an n of
150
with 10 males and 10 females per strain
you've got a pretty firm answer and it's
not just for one genotype of mouse
it's for 150 genotypes that are
segregating for 6 million sequence
variants
which is more than many human
populations
including almost all of west eurasia
so actually almost everything other than
african populations so we've got these
sequins
we're building pan genome assemblies for
these uh critters
um they're extremely powerful for
mapping because the minor allele
frequency is
quite high just like you'd expect for a
linkage study
the precision with which you can map a
causal locus
is on the order of uh half a megabase to
four megabases if you're willing to do
100 strains
and there's a kicker here you can expand
this panel from
120 50 strains to
essentially an unlimited number of f1s
effectively more f1s than you can deal
with and i'll show you that
they can i said nasty things i'm sorry
for those of you who study
knockouts and knock-ins but the nice my
my my mia culpa is you can take your
knockout and you can cross it into the
to the bxd family so we're doing this
with the 5xfad
alzheimer's disease model you never have
to genotype these animals because we've
done it for you
and you shouldn't study more than six
cases per strain
for reasons that are shown right here
if you have a trait that has a
heritability of 0.2 which is pretty low
something like longevity if you study 10
each
your effective heritability is now 0.7
simply because you've gotten rid of the
environmental noise or
various noise sources by averaging
across genome types
these mice are also you can see ideal
for gxe studies because i can take each
pair here
and throw one of the mice in one limb of
the study and another in the other limb
so let's run a randomized controlled
trial or genome by environmental studies
in the bxds
here's a study we did we're just
finishing this with
76 bxd strains all females because we
didn't want them to fight
and we wanted to do a longevity study
and males unfortunately beat each other
up in the cage
we put half of them on it on the normal
chow diet
and half of them on a ridiculously high
fat diet the blue diet for those of you
who know these things
60 calories from fat it's basically like
eating butter all day
uh longitudinal weighings and then we
looked at life span and you can see
the high fat diet animals do
have on average a shorter life span it's
about
85 days we've got two levels of
causality going here
it's it's just a good randomized
clinical control where we basically
randomize these animals across the two
treatment groups fine wonderful that's
how you do it in humans
but we have another level which is the
genetics we have the central dogma we
can map
every one of the traits we can go from
dna to rna to protein to trait
and i should say variability of
here's what the these data look like
where the red are the ciao diet and the
blue i'm sorry the
yeah and the blue are the high fat diet
and you can see oddly enough even though
again
i could give you a general
recommendation hey you know it's going
to be good if you exercise every day
go out and walk or run five miles every
day eat right
you're going to live longer on average
but you
are an individual not a population so
here on the
super high fat diet there are some
strains that actually live
longer on the high fat diet not many but
that one is significant even with all
the
fdr correction and then we as you expect
most strains live longer on the channel
diet but this is one of the parents
so that's the father this is the mother
this is the f1
so you can see the f1s don't care really
whether they're on a high fat or low fat
it's pretty much as a matter of fact
they live a little bit longer on the
high fat
so the one size fits all we've all
been taught that that that's not true
anymore
that's what we call precision medicine
but how do you actually
estimate who which which human is going
to profit
from a high fat diet which human is
going to profit from
smoking cigarettes they're individuals
with parkinson's susceptibility loci
who should smoke cigarettes because
it'll
extend their lifespan
here's just a little surprise weight
and weight gains are not good predictors
of longevity
and in the interest of time i won't go
through this but you can see these
these fits are pretty flat or parallel
so they show that the high fat diet's
not really doing much
well i'm sorry the the high fat diet is
doing something the weight gain is not
doing much
and then uh the bayesian network
analysis so
uh meiotic recombine uh there's
something called
uh bayesian i'm sorry mendelian
randomization that's been introduced to
epidemiology over the last
uh i guess it's about 25 years old but i
think it's really taken off in the last
eight years
um so you can get causality
even out of epidemiological studies now
if you do it in the right
way the more standard way is just to use
kind of the judeo-pearl approach to do
structural bayesian network analysis
this is um bayesian network analysis
run by jan sui using the bayesian
network web server
companion of gene network and here we're
looking at the effects of diet
on total cholesterol hdl free fatty
acids triglyceride glucose
and trying to predict waited 500 days
using all the data i just showed you
and you can see uh you will you will see
that there is no
comparable graph for longevity and
that's because
none of these measures of ldl hdl
glucose total caress
none of them were predictors of
longevity which
was sort of a heartbreak on on one but
but
i am perversely a guy who likes strong
negatives
and it's a reasonably strong negative
with the
way we designed the study
okay so we have we are now at
ten minutes i was going to say a
hands-on
interlude with gene network i'm instead
just going to conclude
but go to gene network and play with it
it's a data loom
um i'm going to skip this i did mention
this
you can expand so everything i showed
you was the inbred strains
i mentioned we have about 150 of these
but there's no reason you can't make any
f1
off the diagonal they're all isogenic
they all have entirely predictable
genomes
and their 22 000 of those to get
beyond mere mechanism so i find
mechanism
a it's the wrong word humans and mice
are not
clockworks we are extremely messy
and we're not machines we are extremely
messy i don't know whatever you want to
call it
processes dynamic processes
this mecha word mechanism just i use it
in grant applications i even use it in
papers but every time i
read it i cringe it's the wrong metaphor
is completely the wrong metaphor for
biological systems
which do not have a necessary and
sufficient
usually other exceptions we really want
to get to robust causal models
with defined predictive accuracy and
error and
we're so here's the kind of rhetorical
question i
answered myself how long will it take us
to reach a goal precision healthcare
without experimental platforms with the
complexity of human cohorts
it's going to it would take forever
basically we would never get there
we need to have cohorts for experimental
precision medicine
and right now the bxds the collaborative
cross
and a few other replicable populations
are it
that's it there's equivalent for
drosophila called the
drosophila diversity panel but there's
not much not nearly enough
and what you're looking at there that
matrix of everybody crossed to everybody
is called the dialel cross and i
that's where i'm going to be going in
the next 10 years i'm going off the
diagonal
into the land of prediction i'm going to
skip this but it's kind of a fun slide
for those of you who are data scientists
some cautions
about becoming a data scientist
don't let the biologists tread on you
you guys are in charge
the biologists will always think they're
in charge because they know the problem
may be better than you do but the
data generation process is critical
and you should you should take charge
um okay you know this is a common lament
of statisticians and data scientists
they get treated as super techs
you do not want to be a super tech you
want to take charge of the problem
and take charge of the biology which is
easier than learning
what you guys know so i wish i knew
matrix algebra i'll tell you that
just want to come back to this uh lovely
um 1939
um piece of poetry by edna st
vincent malay it's it's just it's an
amazing
stands of poetry i can't read it because
it makes me cry every time i read it
it's just
i don't know how she dreamed this up in
1939 but it should be everybody's uh
should be everybody's goal
and uh prospects
so um we we want to align humans and
mouse
uh we can't do it with just mike snyder
and c-57 black six we need a whole lot
more than that
and i think i'll just open it to
questions after saying thanks to the
people who and funding that made this
possible
lots and lots of people helped over the
last 30 years this isn't even complete
but i want to just flag my collaborator
lulu
who's been critical in generating the
animal resources
and peter prince who is the lead
architect of gene network now
it's really a lovely stack of code
i couldn't say this three years ago
i couldn't even say it three months ago
we just finally lifted it over to python
three-point whatever
and just a call out for those of you who
in data science
this this book by judea pearl should be
absolutely required reading the book of
why
all 14 it is
simple some of you might find it
insulting he's
he's kind of got an assertive dogmatic
personality like somebody else i know
um i really really recommend it though
because it'll
allow you to see how ignorant um an
entire field can be for 40 years so
before causal modeling came in
uh the frequentest approach completely
[ __ ] for
uh what we're doing in my opinion and
then thanks to a lot of funding agencies
in particular the governor's chair and
our center for integrative translational
genomics which has made
it possible for me to do crazy crazy
stuff that i wouldn't have been able to
do had i stayed at yale
okay thanks i'm gonna stop share
and i guess i'll start my
start the video that's great thank you
so much
rob for that uh fantastic fantastic and
visionary
like set of thoughts about
uh how we deal with data how we organize
it and how it can
actually live beyond its years and
almost be like you said immortal and i
think that's a very important
point is that data that we collect today
if we organize it properly
and we can figure out ways to make it
available it can actually have
a life well beyond uh the time we
collected it and by the people who
collected it
into many other domains so your talk is
exactly
spot on with some of the uh ideas that i
hope in our
um our biomedical uh
data science uh in uh lab participants
will be able to share with each other
i i we have a couple of questions from
some of our audience members here
yep um and uh yeah uh mentioning uh that
you know you had
discussed the difficulty of managing
data and databases for just the average
laboratory and what advice do you have
for people who are at the early stages
of their careers
that may not yet have an r1 funding
about how they can plan
make plans for managing their data yeah
uh
i like so having lived through it my
advice would be don't
don't don't shy away from excel or
access or filemaker or the equivalent
easy database systems um
if you've got a large flow of data in
your lab let's say you're doing
behavioral studies and you expect to run
through
you know 100 plus animals per year
i would recommend setting up a simple
relational database system
um i'd suggest doing it in your own lab
uh jack and i were talking about cloud
services
i personally don't recommend them i
think they're i think it's as
i shouldn't say this probably
but you know you can buy a 20 terabyte
hard drive for 500 bucks and you can buy
three of them for
1500 bucks and yeah it might be just a
bunch of
disk drives but you you'll be able to
manage it so
i would keep local control unless
there's a good reason not to
the the hardest thing about databasing
is getting making sure you're really
good about
metadata and the header files for your
data
so i i cannot tell you it takes it takes
me probably
10 tries to get a new postdoc to realize
that i don't want to see their excel
file without an
index on the far left going from one to
whatever
and an index along the top showing me
how many columns of data they have
and there have to be at least 10 blank
rows
above that above the data where they put
all their metadata who when where
what why and
if you do that with excel you you add
all those who what where
when why's at the header file
your that data file may be interpretable
in 10 years if you stumble across it and
can open it
but if it's just if it's just an
anonymous it's got some
cryptic header data and no
index you have no idea the provenance
you're doomed
so so the i guess the short answer to
tanya
is metadata so if you
whatever if i don't care if you you do
it in hieroglyphics
if the hieroglyphics have metadata it's
going to be fine
but but if it becomes a matter of
throughput then
go to an easy to use relational database
don't let somebody convince you you have
to do an open source
um code like mariadb or or postgres
because there you do need a lot of
expertise it's
it's free and open but you need
command line competence so i would
suggest if you don't have that
competence
spend a weekend working through
filemaker pro or
the equivalent get competence
filemaker pro now is a very competent
system so it use people used to
you know they put their their nose up
and say oh it's just it's not a
relational database
it may not be fully acid compliant like
the big boys like oracle
but it's definitely good enough and you
can integrate it with all kinds of other
services
so yeah well with that
thank you so much dr williams for that
really
fantastic talk talking about data
structures risk for disease
uh the environmental effects and and uh
how we can
better organize our data and how it can
actually
have usefulness well beyond its original
collection
and uh be useful for folks like the
group we're talking to today is the
data scientists and how they could uh go
to gene network and start playing around
i think that's
wonderful and exactly the type of thing
i'd love to see
some of our participants doing as soon
as possible
be awesome so with that thank you so
much robert i really appreciate it
everyone have a good weekend and we
won't see you next week because of
thanksgiving but uh
enjoy your holiday thanks much and look
any
any comments welcome follow up with the
emails at the very beginning of the
presentation
thanks again robert all right adios